good morning believe nation today we're
going to be talking about the why and
the how of yoga you know my name is rush
still is my company is rush so rush went
to work every day and sometimes I had
insomnia and anxiety and the anxiety
used to feel like the motivating force
if I worry about these things if I have
these things reexamined over and over
again in my mind it will keep me
motivated or working and then I
discovered it of the opposite after yoga
I discovered that the freedom is where
the ideas come from so it's very
important that people lot of work with a
operating from a calm space a calm mind
and I would sell I learned that a calm
mind when in fluctuations are still then
you can see new ideas and you can
envision the world becomes a movie you
get to play your role in that world well
it's not a movie happening to you and
you're an extra you're the lead you
decide your role so then you can rethink
or think properly about everything make
choices because you become the watcher
yogi is the watcher so the intention is
to get to a space where you smile and
breathe in every pose back to the same
idea so this is the intention this is
why we do yoga so we can have more
chances and meditate obviously those two
things go hand in hand
meditation is part of the eight parts of
yoga so you meditate or you move moving
meditation physical yoga because you
want to watch the world and then as good
watches we watch the physical do things
in the world that are productive and
good and inspired as opposed to things
that I'm pushed by anxiety and fear and
other motivational forces I like to
practice every day just kind of centers
me gets me where I need to be mentally
and physically the best thing about yoga
is that you can practice yoga anywhere
which is a pretty fantastic feature for
something to have when you're constantly
traveling it also eliminates gyms which
I can't stand on tour yoga kind of helps
me get centered and kind of relax and
also just to have to get your blood
flowing before you play a show sometimes
if you get thrown into a situation with
flashing lights and crazy fans on the
stuff that is so kind of abnormal so
yoga really helps me prepare for that
thing you know by you know you do
something very natural to kind of
balance they're very unnatural existence
it that you live I practice all over the
world it's so cool you know but we
practiced Island this like I'm a stone
slab in Jamaica overlooking the ocean
and that was pretty unbelievable
it really enhances whatever environment
you're in yoga mentally is just really
calm me down I have a lot of energy and
just kind of relaxed no I need to be
relaxed physically it's just totally
changed my body you know I I used to go
to the gym or I used to trying to be
active in some ways because being active
is important to me but yoga kind of
helped shape my body in a way that I
really liked you know that putting too
much mass on I lift weights and start to
get off me Nikki so there's a weird gray
area with yoga where it does something
it almost does something kind of helps
purify you it really kind of grounds you
and routes you to the earth which is a
very good thing and I'm not a hippie
yeah question is frequently asked about
power and strength in yoga and I'd say
before power and strength comes
flexibility you know when you see Tara
stars doing a yoga you see that she's
flexible but yoga also means flexibility
in your mind flexibility in your
consciousness flexibility that you're
not attached to your habitual
certainties the more flexible you are in
your consciousness the more adaptable
you are the more your body will reflect
that flexibility and a flexible body is
the prelude to strength and power
otherwise again you artificially
introducing strength and power into your
body just by doing certain routines when
the true miracle of the body is that
it's dynamic it's infinitely flexible
and infinitely stable and infinitely
powerful at the same time it's the
coexistence of flexibility strength and
power
that yoga cultivates I have three goals
in my yoga practice there's the
immediate goal the short-term goal in
the long-term goal the immediate goal is
to just enjoy the practice while I'm
doing it and that I do the short-term
goal which as I say is like it could be
measured in weeks or months is to have
increased short-term health and
flexibility and clarity and happiness
and then the long-term goal which I
could measure in years and decades is to
ideally be healthy physically and
mentally as I get older because I look
at the world in which we live and I see
a lot of people especially as they get
older
battling maladies that could be avoided
you know and I think that a yoga
practice both in terms of increasing
strength increasing flexibility
increasing bone density and also it's
sort of spiritual development and
psychological help can enable people or
me to live longer and live happier or
more disease-free life
now you've been into yoga for years and
you also meditate yeah so what are some
of the biggest changes that that has
brought to your life you know I it's
there it's it's kind of not one thing
you could point at or put a finger on
it's just it's just there's I just can
tell you that I feel it just it's like a
kickstart for your day it just centers
you and things your stress levels are
just down and you find yourself
interacting in the world much easier and
better and and cut in a calmer way and
there's just a peaceful joy that that
sort of comes over and you can't I don't
know how or why it's no rhyme or reason
and I just know that if I if I go
through a phase where I slip off and I'm
not this religious with it I feel the
difference yes feel it
tarah any tips or advice for someone who
wants to get started with yoga people oh
sure for people brand new to yoga no
worries you can start wherever you are
if you're alive and you can breathe and
you can do you can be flexible you don't
have to be anything all you have to be
is alive and able to breathe so some
great tips for getting started are ask
your friends and family members if
they're doing yoga where they go maybe
have them drag you along to a class you
can find some good videos on my youtube
youtube page over there formative
DVDs are another good place to start a
DVD coming out or so but I think just
ask some friends and family it's a great
place to kind of get involved in that it
doesn't matter how young you are and a
lot of kids are doing yoga and a lot of
people who were their 50s and 60s you
have an uncle I want to say yeah yeah my
uncle norm is doing yoga on the farm
I know but yeah I mean he you know at
first he didn't want to tell me what he
was doing yoga or cuz he you know I
thought it you know people judge him or
something but he's doing it with the TV
in the morning and we used to call him
Oscar he was really grouchy and
everything but he started doing yoga
Nikhil that was back pain well he's like
super happy now all the time so you know
he didn't start when he was a little kid
so anybody can start this anytime and
receive a lot of benefits so you know
this for everyone it's for everyone so
any misconceptions you want to clear out
maybe someone wants to get started but
they're not sure like what take the
class to go to work so they just walk
into a studio and see how it feels
yeah I mean yoga can be a big turn-off
you know there's a lot of you can a lot
of people you know I talked to her say
they went to a class or a studio and
they just left feeling bad about
themselves or intimidated or you know
they're just like what the heck is this
and yoga should bring you back to you
and have you feeling good about yourself
instead of the opposite so if you're out
of class and you laugh some you just
feel like you know something about that
place didn't feel right just keep going
and you trying to find a new place so
someone who's feeling very good about
you look at these days is Deepak Chopra
and you happen to teach and you got off
with Deepak those so many wonderful
things what's one thing he does in his
yoga practice that we cannot know about
one thing about Deepak is people might
not know because he's such a you know
when I tell people about that I'm
working with Deepak they're like oh no
he doesn't think of himself like that
he's just you and he's a guy that's been
doing this stuff and you know Yoga is
available for everyone if you do a
practice and he's been meditating a long
time and also has loved not medical
knowledge on his background we see what
headstand he's working on it but a cool
thing about him is he's he doesn't take
himself so seriously which translates
into a lot of patience and you know he
doesn't get frustrated we can't do
something today you notice he has a
small life and that's the great thing
about yoga it's not it's not a
competitive sport and your practice keep
coming to it every day
you know your own speed I'll take it
slow fast and just do what's right for
you if you want to learn more about yoga
and need help getting started here are
five video clips that will help you take
action
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Jeff asked me to
so if there's a topic that you want me
to cover in the next edition of believe
life leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of the
points most resonated with you leave it
in the comments and we're gonna join in
the discussion thank you so much for
watching
have an amazing day continue to believe
and I'll see you soon okay should not I
should not be doing this one okay holy I
had it the first time I don't know it uh
you got to put your foot flat against
your I'm on I'm not on solid ground -
doesn't have okay hold on there you go
there you go you should do this okay
okay okay okay okay